hello and welcome to vs toolbox show my
name is Sam Basu Robert Greene is busy
so I'm filling in for today and with me
I have a tribunal and we can talk about
something very exciting especially in
the asp.net land with blazer and web
assembly right yep
so I'm a huge fan of blazer right now
it's an experiment that's being worked
on by the asp.net team Daniel Roth and
Steve Sanderson they're they're working
hard experimenting with this new
framework so I'm happy to have the
opportunity to come on visual studio
tool box and kind of share that story
with everyone awesome tell us more about
so my name is ed Charbonneau I'm a
developer advocate with progress or you
may know them as telluric Sam here was a
developer advocate at progress as well
co-worker of mine and we've kind of
invaded the visual Stube visual visual
studio toolbox episode here to talk
about blazer so I am an author I do some
writing I have a podcast called eat
sleep code and if anybody ever wants to
reach out and get in touch just give me
a shout it on Twitter
okay all right so let's dive in what's
the what's the who plows sounds like
there are some very sharp Minds behind
this at Microsoft and other places tell
us more
so as a web developer that specializes
in c-sharp one thing that I've always
wanted to have is the ability to write
c-sharp and create client-side
applications using it okay so to kind of
back up so with asp.net is it entirely
server-side we can do some things
clients all right but it's all in
JavaScript right now if you want to
write an application that's running in
the browser you're gonna have to
leverage JavaScript but there's some new
things that have come around with
webassembly which is a a way of natively
writing code for your browse browser
that it understands using web standards
this it's a bytecode format okay so it's
similar to an assembly language but it
runs natively inside the browser and the
browser understands so we're starting to
step away from the days where javascript
rules the browser only
we're allowing some new things into the
ecosystem okay so from what I understand
like every browser has a JavaScript
engine right v8 or chakra or WebKit and
it's these engines that run JavaScript
natively in the browser client side so
now we're saying there is something more
that the browser can run and that's the
web standard that you talked about yeah
and I want to point out this is a web
standard because we've tried some things
like this before
uh-huh and well things have changed
things have changed and so maybe to back
up so I'm actually a big fan of
Silverlight back from the days flash was
a was a plug-in and sure it had some
vulnerabilities I think Steve Jobs kind
of wrote a scathing letter one time to
say so essentially when you run flash on
Safari
it makes your tiny iPad heat up and that
not something Steve liked so he
essentially kind of killed the plugins
model and along with it like we never
said Silverlight is done but we just
kind of stopped talking about it and
maybe the plugins model just didn't
scale for the web so now we're saying
we're not gonna do plugins this is
different no no plugins and don't get me
wrong these were things that were
necessary at the time and people were
doing the best you know with the best
tools that they could to build amazing
applications I'm sure there's some just
phenomenal Silverlight applications out
there that people have built but now is
the time to start moving on to something
else we're going to drop all those
plugins and just use things that the
browser understands natively yeah it's a
light though I mean it wasn't just
plugins model like people who did
Silverlight we just enjoyed the dev
experience the rich ecosystem the data
binding with c-sharp and salmon and I
think as developers all of the skills I
mean they move forward with B it you WPB
WPF or salmon forms so you can build
cross-platform apps with the same skill
sets absolutely we're just trying to see
how we can bring that dev mojo bag the
ease of using Visual Studio and c-sharp
but do it differently in the browser
right so how's it so let's start off
with no webassembly how does the browser
work without it so normally we feed the
browser HTML and JavaScript pages those
things go through a parsing and then the
come they are kind of pre compiled and
they are turned into JavaScript tree and
the JavaScript engine inside the browser
interprets that into a a bytecode right
it gets JIT compiled turns into bytecode
and then things happen within the
browser okay so that's kind of where
webassembly happens what they've done is
think of this kind of like for lack of a
better term dependency inversion of
control right so we have this this part
of our browser that understands this
bytecode what if we took that that part
of the browser and exposed that to where
developers could target it so this is
web assembly so we can target this
bytecode now and give that to our
browser and our browser understands how
to execute that bytecode so when we do
that we open up that input to things
like C++ rust go and our favorite
c-sharp okay so now you're talking about
like higher level programming languages
being able to write things that we can
compile down maybe not compile is maybe
not the right word but bring it down to
that low level assembly ish code which
the browser can execute on its own yep
and there's one more clarification to
make here this isn't bytecode that would
run on your machine alright so this
isn't something that's going to get
loose and have security issues it's for
example a library that you send down
isn't going to be able to access your
system registry or run natively on your
Windows desktop okay so it is still
running in the browser shells so to
speak it's very much sandbox and and the
bytecode is only going to be understood
by the browser it's not something that's
used outside of the web so why should I
trust web assembly is this like a
standard that the web community has
accepted absolutely okay so this is a
web standard it's in all the evergreen
browsers and then also if you have
another browser that say maybe on a
mobile device there's some manufacturers
I'd like to ship their own web browsers
and those don't always have standards
that are up to what we expect there are
polyfills that can polyfill and
webassembly
okay so it will be compatible with those
as well all right so you mentioned like
modern browsers so is that like edge
Safari Chrome all of their latest
bits will support webassembly yeah so
when we say something like an evergreen
browser that's one that doesn't have a
hard version number that we're tracking
auto updates for example like IE 7 8 9
or edge you know you're always on the
latest version ok
so Apple is on board with this okay in
Safari Chrome those Firefox the big ones
that that many of the users use those
are the ones that you would expect to
have the the native use of web assembly
and then the other ones like I said the
polyfill works there's a little bit of a
performance gap obviously with that that
type of approach but at least your app
works ok all right so this is where
Blaser enters the picture now there's a
couple modes of how blazer can run one
of those is very new so we'll talk about
that in just a little bit but what I
want to focus on right now is the
experience where you're developing for
the the browser the clients and you're
running the application on the client ok
there is an opportunity to run it on the
server and this diagram doesn't quite
fit that model ok so right now we're
talking client side why white blazer
what was with the name so the blazer
name came from razor so we're gonna use
razor to create our markup for our
application and then the the laser a
part of it comes from the is running it
in the browser yeah in the browser so
browser razor nicey-nicey okay so like
razor is the syntax that we use to build
asp.net applications be it MVC or ASP
nightcore you're saying we're gonna use
the same syntax but it's gonna just run
client-side in the browser
yep so if we look at the the diagram
here what happens is remember that that
model we had before we're gonna feed the
browser HTML and JavaScript only now
we're using the blazer framework and the
blazer framework it renders those those
c-sharp are sorry the the razor CS HTML
files those get turned into HTML which
the browser understands okay then we
take mono so mono the
the runtime that can target multiple
platforms they're now targeting the
browser okay so this is mono under the
covers and I mean in mono as we know I
mean that that's not a new thing I mean
mono has been around since dark nate has
been around so it's the port of dotnet
to other platforms and that's how
xamarin apps run today on iOS Android
not the platform so you're saying we
will use mono to bring your c-sharp down
to ever assembly yes okay so mono is
compiled to run on web assembly and when
blazer is a framework that sits on top
of that now blazer is able to take and
load your dll's directly into mono and
mono is running those and in an
interpreter into the browser okay so it
is being interpreted at runtime now but
eventually you might have a little more
static compile ish and make things a
little more faster yeah so right now
this is the way it's happening
there are I've spoke with Daniel Roth
and there are ideas around maybe
collapsing the stack at a final
compilation stage where all of your
application gets compiled into web
assembly directly so when it loads into
the browser it's at native speeds and
there there's nothing inhibiting that
direct pipeline into the browser now the
way this works now you know this is a
great development experience because
when we compile we're compiling it to
dll's and then mono is handling that
webassembly enter interpretation for us
okay so the compilation time is very
short if we were to take our entire
application and compile it that
compilation time will take quite a bit
of time and our development process
would be slow sure so this is a very
fast way to iterate on an application
and build it and then in the future we
may have that longer compilation and get
the final package you know tightened up
and ready to send down to our users okay
now I see laser jeaious and mono J's
what what are those so those are kind of
intermediate layers for the browser to
help do things like j/s interrupts so we
have a JavaScript Interop layer so
there are things that webassembly
doesn't support yet so there might be
times where we need to fall back on
javascript so we can actually talk to
JavaScript from within web assembly so
from dotnet code you're gonna call it
javascript and back and forth correct
okay so we can actually do that by
directionally you can call javascript
modules and functions from within blazer
interest and then we can also from
JavaScript invoke dotnet functions okay
so that's that's one reason those two
JavaScript files are there they're the
other part is just loading the
application of so the mono j/s takes and
loads bootstraps up the Blazer
assemblies and then blazer has those
Interop layers and communicates down
through mono j/s into those interrupts
directly okay so we've got a nice stack
workflow here that we can build some
pretty interesting applications already
now it's worth saying that blazer is an
experimental project still sure for Anna
we're in release 0.5 dot 1 as of
recording the first 0.1 release was just
in March so it's only six months old
it's a baby it's got a lot of growing to
do but I hear it's come a long way it's
come and tooling quite a long way they
are making some some good investments in
you know producing this experiment and
it's nice to have this experimental
phase because they're able to think
outside the box do some creative
experimentation with it and not have to
worry so much about breaking changes at
the moment and the community gets to
weigh in redevelop to try it out and see
what works and where the pain points are
yeah so back on this diagram I mean this
is all client-side right this is
absolutely all client side and blazer it
can run out of process we we don't need
to necessarily be tied to web assembly
we can do it on the server and we'll get
into a project this is actually
something that shipped in 50.5 dot was
very very how do we can run the
framework on the server side so we don't
have to compile it down and then send it
into the mono
webassembly runtime we can use the
regular dotnet runtime on the server and
then what we're going to do is open up a
signal our hub and communicate across
the hub to your browser and do diffs
between the browser and the updates that
we need to send okay we'll get into that
more we don't want to do much going on
it let's let's look in the client side
first so the client side we've got our
blazer framework running on top of mono
we're able to load dll's directly into
the browser okay which is something very
new and unexpected that that's curious
yeah shows will pull up the network
traffic here and take a look and see
what exactly are you shipping from the
server side when you do blazer apps all
of it worship in dll's down to the
browser and the browser is able to
understand how to run those DLLs thanks
to them on overrun time okay and
hopefully we are doing some some work
with linkers and some tree-shaking so we
are shipping only what we need on the
client side that is stuff that is in the
works coming yes so right now we're
shipping down full assemblies but soon
we hoped that we hope that Steve and his
team will come up with a way to to
create smaller dll's and ship those
across the wire yeah all right let's do
this
yeah so the four we get started will
talk a little bit about the Blazer
framework itself it has a lot of those
things you expect out of a single page
application framework or a spa for
anymore it has a virtual Dom so Dom
manipulation is very taxing effort so
things like jQuery that directly go in
and modify manipulate the document
object model in the browser those things
are sometimes pretty inefficient so
Blaser has its own shadow Dom similar to
other spa frameworks like angular yeah
this almost sounds like very spa
client-side framework but some of the
features like routing and layouts and
dependency injection so we interact with
this virtual DOM and then Blaser does
diffing between the actual Dom and the
virtual Dom so it's only changing what
it needs a change rather than repainting
that entire
that entire dom within the browser okay
okay so where we have efficiency there
we have a component model it's very you
know model view viewmodel type thing
this is something that that developers
from other dotnet frameworks would
appreciate things like uwp and WPF and
silverlight it's not identical but it
has some similar yeah type of service
this is what we liked about Silverlight
development this is the the ease of
doing data binding and and zamel tools
the ecosystem and if you're saying we
can bring some of it back then yeah
let's do it
we have some layout capabilities in
there as well
dependency injection not of the box
something that we'd expect from a modern
dotnet framework so we have that as well
we have routing this very easily follows
that razor pages type of construct where
we we open up a page and have an at page
attribute and we'll show some of that in
a moment and then again the the
JavaScript Interop this part is well so
we'll show that too
so let's jump straight into Visual
Studio now I have some tooling that I
have to install if you want to install
this tooling you go to blazer net and
just follow the step-by-step
instructions there and you'll have the
same tooling that I'm showing now okay
so in Visual Studio I have a file new
project experience for this and I am
going to click on the asp.net core web
application project template and we'll
just do okay here to spin up a new
project and notice I have three new
projects in here and I have a blazer
blazer asp.net core hosted and blazer
server-side so let's dig into these
really quick so before you do that this
has to be a spinet core 2.1 release and
forward yes okay
as of now so as of recording that's what
it is and Visual Studio 15 dot 7 or 8
and those instructions again are on
blazer dotnet you'll find those there
they may be updated after this video
airs so make sure you keep an eye there
but you do need to install these you're
not going to
out of the box in your normal dotnet
installation yeah so our first project
think of this blazer app is a
client-side only template so if you were
to do this in say just normal JavaScript
its terms it would be HTML CSS
JavaScript
static files you run on your client only
mm-hmm okay we're not talking about
server interaction you can still have
server interactions but you do that
through web api's and things like that
they're not included in this project
sure the next one over is the Blazer
asp.net core hosted or I like to call
this the full stack template so this has
the previous project template but it
also includes a asp.net core and some
Web API endpoints that we can hit so
that's kind of like your back-end then
for your app yeah and asp.net is
actually hosting the application as well
with the first example you don't even
really need a host no you just need
somewhere to stick your files and it's
just stuff the browser understands so it
can pick it up and run it sure just like
an HTML Javascript CSS project you could
put it on github pages and host it any
FTP server we have to piece and run
exactly Azure storage you had host your
application from okay using that format
the second one here though this actually
has asp.net core hosting the application
for you it also has a Web API endpoint
for you to be able to hit and it also
has a concept of code sharing remember
we're using the same language now on the
browser client yeah and the server
that's interesting so folks doing nodejs
we are used to doing like JavaScript
front and back and now we can do c-sharp
front and back essentially right
absolutely okay so that's where that one
sits this is a brand new project so this
is where I kind of talked about it a
little bit earlier this is a server-side
model no webassembly involved where the
blazar frameworks it's on the server as
an application and the server connects
through WebSockets down to the browser
using signal are okay those packets with
signal are are sent
they're through a binary transfer so
it's actually taking the diff from your
updates your interactions and sending
that up to the server the server then
processes the changes in blazer
and then blazer knows the diffs to make
sends that down the wire in a binary
packet and then the signal our client
picks it up and replaces what it needs
to in the browser interesting so it's a
very interesting approach to doing this
type of development yeah and if you talk
about like server-side now you're kind
of in node.js territory and you can kind
of think about what this might mean for
electron GIS apps maybe that run on the
desktop but we will get to that but then
this is interesting that we can actually
host laser outside of the web browsers
process and do it all on the server all
that stuff yeah so it's kind of
extending that UI thread across the wire
instead of doing it right there in the
browser on the client so let's actually
jump into this first blazer template so
we can actually show some code and how
this stuff is structured so I'm gonna
spin this up file new project look in
our solution explorer see what we get
some of these things may seem very
familiar out of the box because they
follow conventions that we already use
in asp.net development in particular
this looks familiar if you do any razor
pages so you don't have the
model-view-controller pipeline you have
pages right absolutely render things
from so we'll start top down we have our
WW route okay so this is just like you
would find normally this is static
resources for our application okay we go
into pages like you said razor pages
same idea here we have all of the the
features of our application people like
to talk about apps and features now like
we want to have our in this case our
component feature and our fetch data
feature and we can dive into those files
here in just a moment and then our
shared libraries our shared views and
same same concept is asp.net we have
things like templates and our main
layout and even we can even have a view
imports file so to do those
global using statements and bring in
component libraries and things like that
okay and another familiar concept is the
startup in program dot CS files that you
find in dotnet core projects those are
the things that bootstrap your
application and configure dependency
injection and all those great things
okay
so let's give this guy a run we'll get
this started and kick it off in the
browser and then we'll go look at the
code behind it is Express but you just
said it may not need
yeah we've we don't really need to do
all that we could we could host this on
github pages if we wanted to these are
all static files that that we're using
here and so we get our hello world app
we have a couple features here we have
our counter component mmm we can click
an increment a counter you're not coming
back to the server so no there is no
server okay we're not doing any data
transfer across in anything right now
we have a fetch data but it's all being
handled locally so we're just grabbing a
JSON file and just pumping the data into
the into the application so we're
grabbing that static JSON file it's not
coming from web service or anything at
this point
so right now kinda looks like an average
application but let's see how it's built
so let's dive into some of the features
here let's open the counter component or
the counter page you'll notice right
away this is the Razr syntax it's a dot
CS HTML file and it uses very familiar
conventions it does yes at the very top
we have our router so page is at the
counter endpoint so if we go to counter
and our browser that's where we end up
and that rounding is built-in now
routing is built into the framework so
now we have just simple HTML here we
have our header tag and then we have our
current count and then we're using razor
here to display a value of current count
sure and we have a button to click and
then we have a vent binding to the on
click event and then we have a function
block here that
has our functionality for this page so
there's our current count that's being
bound up here and we have our event
handler for the increment okay when you
say at functions like that's soo sharp
right yeah this is razor and everything
inside of this block is C sharp code
yeah yeah so there's no JavaScript at
all on this page and when we click the
button it invokes this increment count
function and it's data bound to this
this current count value so that's the
view that we see here when we click this
button mm-hmm so we're able to do that
with very little code it's all there's
no post backs going to the server it's
all being handled locally on the client
in a very easy to understand fashion
okay so if you go back to the browser
for a second so you said this is it it
has a shadow Dom but there is a dumb out
there so if you right click you will let
you to see HTML yeah absolutely so those
c-sharp or CSS HTML files are being
rendered out into the browser so you see
your bootstrap rows and your link your
links and your buttons and all those
good things let's let's actually jump
over to our network tab while we're in
here and just do something interesting
let's do empty cache and reload and when
this comes down across the wire notice
that we're actually sending the ll files
from the server mm-hmm Gary so let's see
these all get loaded in through web web
assembly ok and our our application
spins up and it's all client-side okay
so we're actually running these dll's
locally on the client that's very
interesting you're literally shipping
dotnet dll's to the browser tab setting
it figure it out at runtime and you like
if you look at the sizes this is where
you're saying it'll get better
like we'll ship smaller and smaller as
we go yeah yeah right now you can see
that we're shipping the.net standard DLL
and a score Lib and all these things as
a whole across the wire I would imagine
I'm not on the dev team just for
clarification
but I've had discussions with Daniel
Roth the PM on the team and he's he's
adamant about making these things
smaller and more compact when they go
across the wire sure so let's jump back
into code again we'll take a quick look
at the fetch data this is the view that
if we click fetch data here we have a
little bit of a grid showing some data
that's coming in the first thing I want
to point out again we have routing and
then underneath routing we have this
@inject declaration up here so this is
actually calling out to the dependency
injection system and it's asking for the
HTTP client that's registered in
dependency injection so that's going to
get resolved and then down in the code
of this page you'll see we use that HTTP
client to go to a file on local storage
okay you're not going anywhere just a
JSON that you're loading but you could
go across the network if you wanted
could make requested back-end services
and all those types of things
and we're doing it in a familiar dotnet
way and we're using HTTP client and
doing a get Jason async to pull in a
object type of an array of weather
forecasts so there's Jason binding
that's happening on automatically in
here so we don't need to even worry
about those type of things
sure and then there's our weather
forecast object right there right so
we're getting these values and just
mapping those values from the JSON into
this object and then we iterate over
those in the view so at this point is
this would you say these are views or
would you say these are components so
the these are both actually so we have
the concept of a page here we're using
this at page directive with the routing
but I could actually come into my home
or my index and
let's wipe this component out for a
moment and I can come in here and type
and counter notice the nice intellisense
come up and we'll close that tag and
I'll come back to my browser and refresh
and let's go home and really for it to
refresh that we're getting a message we
I'm actually in debug moves and let's
let's actually run this a different way
let's do let's do a control f5 so we'll
run without debugging so we can refresh
this experience now remember this is an
experimental project okay so the
debugging experience right now is a
little lackluster there's some work
being done to make debugging available
in the browser we can actually at
current state set breakpoints in sushar
in the browser we can set breakpoints
we'll look at that in a few moments
because I don't want to get too
off-track so we'll be able to at some
point we'll be able to debug c-sharp
code in chrome or IE Wow at current
States not quite there but it's getting
there
so back to talking about the components
do you have the Contra taking that
entire page use it as a component I said
so and that's not something you were
able to do at all in asp.net MVC or core
or razor that's right this is a new
component component so this is kind of
like in some ways like angular and react
you're just absolutely plopping a
component down into a page absolutely
just very similar concepts of those
things you could say it was it was
inspired by or borrowed from those which
those things and for inspired by and
borrowed from things like WPF we
rediscovered the same problems over and
over again so let's let's have a little
fun with the counter component that we
have we'll go back to this page here and
let's set up a property so we actually
have a shortcut for this now in the
tooling and we can say instead of prop
tab tab which we might be used to to do
this we can say para
tab tab and now we get the parameter
attributes and then we can expose a
property on our component so let's call
this count by so this is an integer that
we'll set to be count by and instead of
just incrementing this internally we can
just say plus equals count by we might
want to set a default value here what if
they don't pass in the parameter so
we'll do that okay I saved it we'll go
back to our index and now we can say
count
I may have to recompile here let's do a
build and now we can do kell by there we
go
now our intellisense comes up and we
needed to build that library out I can
set that to an integer of 5 now and
we'll save this and we'll refresh our
page so if I'm getting this right so
these are individual components so the
actual counter should still increment by
one but this one should pick up the
parameter right so the instance of the
counter on my index page counts by five
yeah
and the instance of the counter on the
counter page is only counting by one
sure but now we've extended that
component out and actually made it a
little more robust where we can have
like a developer experience where you
can type in and get a tell us and set
variables and properties on on the
object
so a very simple component model to
understand this is absolutely simple to
get up and running
let's do file new project will do
asp.net core web application again this
time we'll do the full stack version now
it's important while it spins up will
will kind of outline when I say full
stack we're not doing server-side
rendering okay so we're still using that
client-side we're gonna ship everything
to the browser let it run on web
assembly I'm not doing ahead of time
compilation of the views and sending any
HTML down the wire other than the
bootstrapping index page sure that's it
so it's something that we just need to
clarify so people don't expect that
those raisers those razor views are
being compiled on the server and HTML is
being sent back to the server for data
like essentially yes so if we look at
this it's exactly what you said we have
our client app which is the same exact
thing that we saw before now we have a
server project and the server project
has a Web API controller and this is
going to supply that weather data that
we saw coming from a static file before
okay so this is a Web API endpoint with
a get action on it and it's just gonna
randomize some weather data for us yeah
and you can hook this up to any data
source you want it could be a cloud
service and Azure function nodejs all
the above our sequel server sitting
under my desk cognitive services do some
cool machine learning stuff there so
this is just wave API and I can do crud
operations like create read update
delete absolutely okay and then notice
we have a shared library all right so if
we're on the client and we're gonna
iterate over a list of weather forecasts
mm-hmm so this is the same view that we
saw before an array of weather forecasts
is coming in from this get Jason async
and the server sending a list of weather
forecasts right then the weather
forecasts can live in a shared location
where both projects can access that
class type ICN is that like how would
you share is that like a dotnet standard
library okay and so this is a dotnet
standard library it's being referenced
if I go into my dependencies under
projects there you go you can see shared
yeah and it's it is actually using
the.net standard libraries well reuse
this from summer and if you want it to
yes you could share it not only across
Blaser projects but any dotnet standard
project and that also opens up this to a
whole ecosystem of things that already
exist mm-hmm so think about that for a
minute we'll actually have a demo at the
very end here where I've gone in and try
some of these things like sixteen one
good packages after some bringing okay
yeah new gets dotnet standard packages
that are on nougat within reason they
work within blazer now if they have some
kind of direct access to the system
there they're looking at you know your
system temperature and registry or
things that belong on maybe Windows not
gonna happen what you can do though is
load in things that are you know
business logic and stuff like that and
I'll show a use case for that it where
it's been successful for me okay so this
is the other project mmm-hmm and we've
got the same type of structure but
inside of fetch data we're actually
going out to an end point now and
pulling that data in through an API we
have a shared logic folder these are all
very good things to help us be
productive sure so on in this solution
you could host the server in IAS or
anything that you host in asp.net
application in and then the client could
just be served up from anything you want
it so it's all client-side absolutely in
this scenario though the the client
application is actually being served by
dotnet core but you could split those
out if you open unto all right so let's
look at another project I'm gonna open
this one this is I didn't want to do too
much live coding here so I know I will
fat-finger something and we'll have some
demo fails so I kind of pre created it
here let's do pull it off my start page
here I want to show the concept of
having external component libraries so
there's currently no file new project
experience for creating a component
library from within Visual Studio
there is tooling however we can drop
down to the command line we can type in
dotnet new laser Lib so I say that
dotnet new blazer Lib will spin up a
project that is boilerplate for creating
component libraries okay so let me back
have you said to CLI so all of this
laser stuff I can do it
- CLI as well yes and there's a nougat
oh sorry there is a well technically
it's a nougat package so you go into
your command-line dotnet new - I will
install and then you point to that
package and it will install those
command lines and if this is a document
core I can do this on Mac or Linux right
yep okay again
blazer dotnet and you're getting started
you'll find those CLI commands okay so
we don't have to people don't have to
try to memorize them as we same here on
the show yeah that's the best place to
find them blazer net so we have our
client application and we have another
library called my components mm-hmm and
I have a component in here called my
component really cleverly named
component here and I've put that
component on my index page so on my
index page you have my component so
you're referencing your component
project from inside the blazer project
obviously and then you're able to just
render that and does the component have
other nougat dependencies that you're
pulling in right now it's just dependent
on the Blazer libraries so if I look in
in.net standard you see we have our
blazer libraries here right it's
dependent on browser and build if we
come into our dependencies on the client
application you can see I have a
dependency on my components and then
that dependency is registered in the
view imports file so here it's being
registered as a tag helper this is
another familiar concept from our dotnet
core asp.net core mind sets okay I'm
registering any components that exist in
the my components library I'm
referencing and that allows me to drop
it on my index page so let's take a look
at what this component does so this the
code looks almost in to go to just
rendering a component that's inside of
your client project but you're just
pulling this in yep so I have this big
box with a dashed line most of this is
actually boilerplate I've modified it
slightly so we have a cool demo for the
show I'm just kind of wired up what our
ad exists in that template just seemed a
give it a little
or flair so I'm gonna click on this box
and now I've got a prompt and I can type
anything in here I'll say hello vs
toolbox and hit OK and now that data is
represented and it's bound inside of
that that dotted box there so let's see
how that works so again my component
look at my component CS HTML it's a
simple div binding to the handle click
function handler alright or click
handler it's got a regular CSS class on
it of my component and then I have a
value called message so I'm going to
create a placeholder for it string
message equals click here to change
that's the default value and then
whenever I click handle click I'm gonna
set the message and this is gonna do it
asynchronously and it's gonna make a
call to JavaScript hmm and it's gonna
display a javascript prompt in the
browser not true so making a call to
JavaScript from my c-sharp code and then
when that comes back we're just gonna
notify Blazer that the state of the view
has changed and it needs to do an update
to the shadow Dom now if I dive in to my
component you'll see this content folder
this is put here by the template and
inside of that are resources that belong
to the component including this example
javascript interrupts so this is a
JavaScript module and it's being loaded
into the global namespace of the window
here so on window we have our scope of
example J's function and a function
called show prompt right and then that
prompt takes an argument of a message so
we can set that prompt to whatever we
want and then it returns the values that
that was put into the prompt so how is
the name show prompt different from what
you were calling from a Java Script I
thought he just said prompt ok so
there's a nice little wrapper
of syntactic sugar around that if I open
up example jeaious Interop I see so
there's a little she sharp extension
method in here and it's called example
J's Interop and sorry it's not an
extension about just a static method
it's asynchronous so it uses a task it
returns a tasket string and it takes in
the prompt message and returns a string
value as a task so here's where it's
calling that scope and then that
function in JavaScript okay so at this
point you're kind of mixing and matching
JavaScript and darknet on the client
side and so if you have existing
JavaScript assets and functions you can
call them from dotnet yes so if you have
existing JavaScript libraries that you
love and don't they're too big to maybe
translate over or you want to have a
moment where you're migrating goes in
between yeah yeah okay so you can do
some migration there or web assembly may
not target certain things yet so for
example we can't pull up a prompt
natively in c-sharp through web assembly
so we need to reach out to JavaScript to
say hey we need a prompt and we're able
to do that so we have that flexibility
and this is how it's done okay that's
very interesting and at the same time we
we got little experience with developing
component libraries right and you can
see there's no at page directive on this
one it's just HTML a little bit of
c-sharp and razor and it's very easy to
understand what's happening inside of
the system all right so let's do the
server-side example now now this is
where it's gonna make it confusing for
me aren't you let's see this is
interesting so we've been talking a lot
about web assembly we're gonna get away
from that for a moment we're gonna
actually do all this in the browser or
sorry in the server okay we're gonna
create a blazer application that is
running on the server and all of the
data is going to be handled through a
WebSocket so the application on the
client is just going to be a very thin
client it's just an HTML page
that spins up a signal our listener
connection back to the hub oh no sir
yeah so there's a hub on the server
that's all part of the application
framework so we don't we don't really
have to concern ourselves with all of
that it looks exactly like the previous
few examples let's run this guy
well that spins up I'm going to fire up
yet another application this is fiddler
by progress under the telluric brand
something that you and I know and love
most web developers cannot live without
fiddler and fiddler is a free tool that
you can download and use and it's very
helpful for working with HTTP
connections and things like that because
I want to show you when we're running
this WebSockets kind of perform a little
different than your normal requests do
so the server has sent down the
application through the signal our
pipeline we have this active connection
back to the server you know and we can
do updates like this and pull in data
from our application and we can do all
this using that signal our hub okay so
this one this is not running purely
client-side yours there's actually
almost nothing running client-side in
this scenario
so let's actually open this guy up let's
hope the network tab and again we'll do
reload
notice all the DLLs aren't coming down
this time no they're not because they're
staying on the server they're running on
the server and we have a small
javascript file that's handling all of
this for us and just sending back
changes through that that signal our
pipeline so how does that server know
about the Dom if you had to do anything
so the that's in the diffs that it's
sending back and it's a binary package
it's sending to Blaser to to make those
changes so for example if I navigate
here let's clear this window out
and let me come down let's go to fetch
data notice the data loaded so their
data the data is in here and we didn't
make any kind of communication back and
forth let's do the counter component I'm
clicking
there's no communication back and forth
you might and the surface think that
you're not communicating with the server
yeah let's pull up fiddler and hopefully
this works for me
I'm let's try to put this side-by-side
and we'll do a click and I'm getting a
demo fail so let's try clearing our is
fiddler responding fiddler just up there
we go something was some kind of lag
here so let me try again
and for some reason fiddler doesn't want
to behave with this demo so we'll have a
little demo fail normally what we'd have
we'd be able to open this up and fiddler
would actually show the socket traffic
so dev tools does not capture rep
sockets traffic either can it may I just
don't know where to look it was there so
it may be a little bit of my
inexperience with the WebSocket traffic
in the tooling here I it does normally
show up in fiddler though all right
so every time I click this we're
actually no actually we we've frozen up
there when we click this we're we're
actually sending some traffic through
the socket up to the server okay
again that's this is what happens when
you work with experimental bits and
things don't always happen you pray to
the by the way you look back bigger than
you get the point so this is running
server-side almost nothing on the
client-side and you are piping content
through a WebSockets channel or a tunnel
essentially yeah absolutely
so one other very big difference that
you'll notice remember before when we
did our dependency injection on that
fetch data something is a little bit
different here so since we're on the
server we don't need to send
HTTP requests hmm so we can just new up
a service forecast service this could be
maybe a layer over the top of an ad
framework or something like that
but we don't have to send a web requests
because we're on the server with the
data in the application and all of that
and we can just say get the forecasts
asynchronously and do it that way so our
dependency injection actually looks
different as well so we don't we're not
injecting an HTTP client
we're just injecting the service which
is a c-sharp class yeah so this is
interesting you're you're hosting the
data on the server and you're also
running the app right next to it so you
can get the data just as quickly mm-hmm
see we have our weather forecast service
in here and it's just creating a task an
asynchronous task to turn returned that
array and like I said that could be your
database there okay so no HTTP call so
that's an interesting mode of operation
mm-hm
let's let's do one last demo where we
show a project that a that I've created
and used some existing dotnet assemblies
from nougat so let's hope so I got to
stop this guy from running first and
then we'll see if I can grab it off my
start page and I've lost it here so
let's do open project and the project is
called blazed down I figured I'd go with
the theme browser + raisers Blazer
markdown + blazer is blazed down let's
do a little bit of blazed down so this
is a markdown editor ok completely
written in Blazer hmm so I'm gonna run
this up and it's a client-side
application running on the browser only
ok there's no server code in here so
we're gonna get the application the
browser loads it up we have marked down
here on the left and we have the
rendered markdown here on the right okay
it's a very cheap markdown editor that
we can just come in here and live edit
and then those changes persists on the
other side we can use some of our
markdown syntax to change things like
headings and do code highlighting for
example all of those things are are
working here right in the browser and
being rendered as HTML on the other side
sure you might expect a lot of code
behind this right yeah this is you know
I'm parsing I'm parsing mark mark down
into HTML in real time and you are you
doing this yourself or do you bring in
some libraries I'm I'm not the smartest
guy in the room ever Sam so I'm actually
using something someone else created so
there's an existing library called mark
dig so there's a dependency in this
application and if I look under
dependencies and under new get we've got
something missing here oh it's actually
in a component sorry I've moved it out
to a component so our dependency is in
that component itself so I have a
markdown component nougat and there's
mark dig ok so this is off the shelf I
haven't modified it in any way shape or
form pulled it into my project and just
started using it right away
I don't know anything about making an HR
a markdown parser and it needs to
somebody already did the hard work for
me I can just pull that into my
component if I open up my component the
component takes and runs a function
called build HTML from markdown and I
pass in this content value which is
whatever you're typing into that text
box okay that runs this function called
build HTML from markdown and returns at
HTML using this method here called to
HTML and sends that back as a string and
then that string is loaded as raw HTML
into the component displaying it in the
browser ok and all of this is now
running client-side entirely this entire
thing is running clients
so mark Digg is running on the browser
using the dll's that come out and again
those are actually running right here in
the browser I can do things like pull in
I can use that HTTP client to pull in
markdown files from another resource
maybe github or something like that I
don't know if if people saw that I'll
clear this out I can do import and it'll
go back and pull in that original file
that I was using before and then I can
also do something cool here I can say
download is markdown and click that
button and I'm prompted with a markdown
file so at this point you were on the
client side and you downloaded a file
from the client side that was generated
client side as well right the markdown
file is that like an output off the mark
dig so extension that's what we're gonna
get to now I'm glad you brought that up
Sam I have a download component here oh
so there's another compliment there's
another component and this is called
download button so this component has an
on click event that's when you click the
actual button itself it has a property
called payload and a property called
filename mm-hmm so if we look at our
index page here you'll see the actual
component being used download button
here and I'm setting the value to that
same content valium binding all these
things are just being bound to content
value the markdown editor itself the
output and the button are all binding to
the same set of data and then I set the
file name to whatever I'd like that to
be and then when somebody clicks the
button let's look inside of our button
so we go to download button on clicked
event fires and I'm using a JavaScript
interrupt so the JavaScript interrupt is
necessary in this scenario because of
browser incompatibilities mm-hmm so I
initially wrote this with no JavaScript
what so
and you're able to do this in Chrome
through a special type of URL that you
can just set a prompt and click a button
and that that URI translates into a file
download that's not possible on edge
edge has a special API that is custom
for edge called MS Save Bob
so I've wrote an interrupt that wraps in
a slave's say blob there's basically a
simple browser check so if I go in here
there's a function in here called
is HTML download allowed and there's
also one to say is in a saved blob
allowed so we check to see is is MF say
Ms saved blob a function that exists in
the browser if it's not that means we're
probably not on ie rich and then it
fails over to the next mode which is
this HTML download that is more
Universal and then finally if no browser
support is there we'll just throw a
console message and you won't see that
download come across okay so that that
gets invoked when we click that button
and but this project is a good example
of how I can use existing neck
technologies going to new get pulling
some packages write very little code
almost everything that exists in the end
blaze down you just saw on the screen
just a couple properties here and there
and a couple function calls and I'm able
to make something really cool like this
indeed indeed so that's very interesting
splays are in a nutshell right now zero
point five point one is the current
release it just came out a couple weeks
ago it may be updated by when the
recording comes out on visual studio
toolbox but just check blazer net for
updates sure and see how that turns out
and you're running an interesting sure
that ass goodbye was good but it sounds
like you're not really saying goodbye to
JavaScript you can do JavaScript and
diamond inner up but just like
JavaScript runs natively in the browser
on the client side now you got c-sharp
running natively on
plans that as well yeah my sure does say
goodbye JavaScript hello c-sharp and
blazer but I don't wish any you know bad
will towards JavaScript course it's
still there's still some great
frameworks out there that a lot of
people are using this is just another
option for dotnet developers and people
that may want to use net for using doing
web technologies and creating
browser-based applications yeah yes so
sounds like I mean if you are a.net
developer and you you want to stay on
top of modern web but you don't want to
write a whole lot of JavaScript this is
a way for you to write C sharp straight
up in the browser and run it natively
what about performance I mean we are
running native performance in the
browser not yet so again this is only
like six months old sure the performance
I mean if you look at blaze down it's
pretty performant it does a good job
you're not supposed to be using this
framework for building production
applications because of the state that
it's in is an experiment the performance
isn't going to be as good as JavaScript
at the moment okay but you know it's
it'll get there over time at least I
feel like that's the direction it's
headed in and I think Daniel Roth and
his team have a pretty good outlook on
what's happening yeah and it sounds like
I mean this is not just a Microsoft or
to Google or an Apple thing as long as
webassembly gets better at executing
those byte codes we'll get more and more
performance out of it yeah nothing about
web assembly is Microsoft it's the the
w3c standard it's a standard technology
that browsers are implementing all the
other evergreen browsers have it other
technologies are looking at targeting it
there's go compilers Russ compilers C++
so this is just another flavor of web
assembly and a really cool framework
built on top of it sure thing so sounds
very exciting what's next so they just
keep an eye out on what the asp.net team
is doing and Blaser is open source now
part of the github repo yes a blazer is
open source and blazer net or look for
it on github
and further down the pipeline we'll see
some some more experimentation there's
actually a project out there of using
electron with blazer and using that same
signal are type server-side experience
but it's using the electron shell
instead it's yet another avenue for this
cool technology to take off and the
experiments just keep producing really
interesting things on it yeah
clearly you're pumped and I think if you
are a c-sharp developer and you want to
see where your code can go definitely
keep I mean it behooves you to kind of
keep an eye out on blazer and where this
is heading very much yeah all right well
thank you so much for sharing all this
knowledge and all the cool stuff that
they sped up in a team and Steve
Sanderson and Dan Roth and those guys
are building this is very exciting so
we'll see what what comes out of this
and yeah this evolves yeah hats off to
them it's it's really cool stuff and
I've just been watching and enjoying all
the things they're making and trying to
you know help with issues on github and
if if you get a chance to try this out
get the bits click on the survey button
that comes with the example application
fill out the survey get in touch with
them on github know what your needs are
so they they know where to steer the
framework in her and better yeah and
just like anything else in asp.net its
open-source and sounds like the
community this is the perfect time for
us to play around and make sure we are
doing this together yeah all right very
exciting very cool stuff so this was all
about blazer on vs toolbox hopefully all
of you guys enjoyed it keep an eye out
on how this evolves very exciting times
ahead and thank you so much for being
with us on this vs toolbox show thank
you and bye for now